hello everyone and welcome back to
another incredible game of the Dos
Hermanas Tournament of 1996 it is vishan
Tanana versus alexe shirov and although
you know the standings of the tournament
by now and you know uh pretty much
everything that happened I did mention
that Anand had the most wins in the
entire tournament only player to get
four wins and this is his first game of
the tournament against the master of the
Mystic Arts Alexa shirov um they're
roughly the same age Anand is I believe
3 years older he's 31 here Sher of 8 I
believe and uh the the chest is very
much different than what you would see
today nowadays when you have a grandm
surprised by another Super grandmas or a
member of the top 10 for example un move
22 uh it's not uncommon for them to fall
apart after two or three moves but in
those days even though you got
completely surprised you still you know
you still got to create you still got to
to play an incredibly difficult game to
calculate and that's exactly what
happened here so let's dive straight
into it on with the white pieces opens
with Pawn to E4 Shiro replies with Pawn
to G6 for goes for the modern defense or
the robach we have Pawn to D4 Bishop to
G7 and now Knight to C3 we have Pawn to
C6 the ganit variation and Bishop to C4
now nowadays I believe it is more more
popular to develop the nice Knight first
but Anand has no plans of developing the
Knight to F3 that's why he probably
chose this line D6 and queen to F3
immediately going for that F7 Pawn so
Pawn to E6 and Knight G to E2 we have
Pawn to B5 attacking the bishop Bishop
B3 and pawn to A5 now threatening to
trap the bishop with Pawn to A4 so Anand
makes uh some breeding room for the
bishop on A2 and Bishop to A6 and now if
you Castle then okay the light squ
Bishop could be very relevant here banan
goes for D5 first the black king is also
in the center of the board we have C
captures e captures and now of course
you don't want to give un any useful
squares uh on D5 uh so just Pawn to E5
we have Knight to E4 and now Pawn to H6
it's a very important move uh because
you really want to play F5 but you can't
play it right away if you play it right
away then Knight G5 and how do you stop
Knight A6 you have to go back with
something like Bishop to C8 H but even
then even if the Knight is captured the
bishop will be guarding this Pawn on E6
is going to be a mess for black to play
this so instead Knight E4 Pawn to H6
stopping Knight G5 from Anand and pawn
to G4 Anand says I do not want to see F5
on the board let's play G4 and then we
continue probably I'm not castling King
side but you never know Pro okay Bishop
D3 will probably happen and then castles
Queen side so okay Knight to F6 and now
Knight to to G3 saying okay you can
capture but I'm still going to have a
knight on e4 uh Knight captures Knight
captures and now finally Castles by
shirov and D F5 square is also now
guarded by The Rook so he might be
considering a push with Pawn to F5 we
have Queen H3 going after that H6 pawn
and here comes a most interesting reply
Pawn to F5 right away but not with the
idea that first um comes to mind that if
captures just captures oh no uh G
captures an F5 and now Bishop to C8 as
the pawn cannot move and if if you play
G captures an F5 it looks like something
shirro might do and it might look even
interesting but uh White is completely
winning here and it's a quite an
interesting line or a set of lines
because any line here wins for white
let's say Rook G1 goes after the bishop
here and now if you take the knight uh
uh doesn't really work Rook captures on
G7 and after King captures Bishop
captures on H6 and you either go here
which I mean uh then white can just
Castle put the Rook on G1 and there's no
uh safety for the black king or you go
here and then just Queen E6 is Checkmate
right away or if you don't capture the
Knight it doesn't really matter what do
you do let's say you play Rook A7 you
stop the capture then then comes Bishop
G5 look at this absolutely disgusting
you cannot capture because then Knight
to G5 comes controls F7 and H7 then
Queen H7 happens or if you move the
queen then you play Knight to F6 check
with this wonderful Royal Fork uh the
bishop could move but then it runs into
a discover check from Rook but if Rook
captures still Bishop captures and it's
it's not much better to give an example
Bishop captures Bishop captures with
check King H7 and now Bishop to G5 how
do you stop Queen captures on H6 only
the queen can do so and once the queen
comes to G7 now you will castle and I
mean absolutely disgusting position to
have with black you can double Rooks on
the G file the queen is stuck here
guarding H6 no other pieces can come to
help you're probably going to even play
C3 Bishop to C2 and no surviving this so
of course that's why shirov played
Bishop to C8 and now Knight back to G3
and here uh you might expect something
like Pawn captures or Bishop Capt but no
Shir plays Rook captures on F5 and
interestingly even though this was
played in 1996 the position has been
reached a few more times after that uh
and uh even the the The Rook was
captured last game that was played
between two grand Masters was in 2006
and The Rook was captured here but
that's not the the way to go because if
Rook captures Bishop captures uh Black's
position is just overwhelming then now
the queen moves the Knight comes to D7
then the Knight can come to C5 and it's
just a uh wonderful position for black
with no real weaknesses uh because
there's no E Pawn or G Pawn to tackle
the bishop uh it's just much better for
black so instead after Rook captures on
F5 Anan played Queen to G2 and it is now
as of move 18 that this position has
never been reached again so even in the
pre-eng engine era Anand played the
strongest move recommended by then
non-existing engines uh and okay Pawn to
A4 going after the bishop uh forcing the
bishop to come to A2 uh so you don't
have something like C3 and Bishop to C2
so Bishop to A2 and now Rook to F4 again
shirov no wonder you know he he has such
a reputation for being such a creative
player he's offering The Rook once again
but now if the bishop takes the Rook
then e captures attacks the Knight and
then Queen F6 with the threat of F3 uh
and also just going after that B2 Pawn
completely shattering White's King side
and queen side so instead after Rook F4
Anan just plays C3 he wants to figure
out way on how to get that Bishop back
into the game and now Rook to H4 again
very tricky by shirov if unand castles
then Bishop to H3 will just be winning
and even if you don't Castle Bishop to
H3 is a very scary move to face so all
has to play H3 and now Bishop to F5 and
this is the first time in the game that
shirov plays a slight inaccuracy which
is uh more than unneeded to take control
of this game the way to continue this
properly is to go E4 and the reason is
if you capture then you just give up the
E file uh to to Black you open up the E
file and also you can never Castle
because of Bishop captures an H3 and if
you don't then you just bring the Knight
here and with the Knight on E5 having
access to F3 and D3 it would be very
tricky to play this but he played Bishop
to F5 he prepared Pawn to E4 uh but now
it's anan's turn to strike now Anan
plays Knight captures on F5 G captures
and queen to G6 okay very annoying
putting pressure on the F5 Pawn also
Rook to G1 might happen also uh well if
the Rook moves the bishop can capture on
H6 uh so very tricky stuff here even if
Rook G1 Bishop can capture on H6 right
away and if Rook captures Queen captures
as The Rook will control the G file so
quite a lot for shiru to handle here and
queen to F6 is by far the best you have
to offer a queen trade and then uh well
Anand will probably not trade he will go
for something like Queen to check then
the queen blocks with Queen to f8 and
Anand has to decide what to do whether
to go back or maybe even to capture the
pawn on B5 so probably due to you having
um to lose the B5 Pawn shirov decides to
go Queen to f8 and now Bishop to E3 uh
okay uh the Anand is preparing to Castle
Queen side no secrets there King to h8
uh freeing up the bishop and now Queen
side castles now the other Rook can come
to G1 and the black king will be uh well
uh uh stressed out to to say the least
we have Knight to D7 uh and now Queen to
E6 Queen to E6 is a very good move by
Anand but I'm going to show you a line
uh it's it's a disgusting Engine line
and something a human would not uh find
but it's Bishop to B1 point is that okay
you're threatening to capture on F5
which would go great with your plan of
checkmating the black king on H7 but
then after E4 Pawn to F4 and now again
if you capture alaan just Bishop
captures on F5 and black is doomed uh
and if you don't capture well The Rook
on H4 is just trapped
uh you can capture it right away but
that Rook is never coming back into the
game and another thing black can no
longer just trade Queens because if you
go into an end game Shiro will have a
rook that's uh unable to join the the
party stuck on H4 so yeah disgusting Eng
stuff I know but I thought you guys
would appreciate that so Queen to E6
also a very strong move by Anand uh now
Rook to d8 defending the Knight Here and
Now Rook D to G1 uh just preparing Rook
to G6 which will be very unpleasant for
black and then maybe even doubling up on
the H file so Pawn to F4 uh getting the
bishop um off of this nice diagonal and
now the question is do you bring the
bishop back to D1 or do you play Bishop
to A7 those are your only two moves and
uh although it does make sense to play
Bishop to D2 you know sort of to keep
your king safe and maybe to somehow be
relevant in the attack happening on the
king side uh Bishop to A7 is much
stronger and that is what Anan plays
point being that Knight to C5 cannot be
allowed if the Knight comes to C5 get
getting access to B3 uh D3 E4 uh black
will be better so uh you have to stop
Knight to C5 if Knight C5 then you just
capture it right away uh so Knight to F6
now uh and the bishop to B1 finally the
bishop gains control of this diagonal
and now okay there are some tricks here
like Queen coming to F5 Rook G6 Rook
captures Knight eliminating uh the
defender of D H7 Square check mating the
black king that's all an option but it
can be prevented Rook to E8 sheru
continues with the strongest uh move
order B Queen to F5 and now Queen to F7
again if you go for something like Rook
to to G6 uh and Rook captures here uh
the queen will be guarding the H7 square
but Queen F7 also comes with Tempo it's
attacking the bishop on A7 so Anand has
to move it first H and now what do you
play here with shirov it's a it's a very
hard position because there really
aren't that many moves uh Rook to H5 of
course is one of them that's why the
queen is also so strong on F7 the other
one being Rook to B8 attacking the
bishop and Rook to B8 is the strongest
move recommended by the engine uh but it
just doesn't make all that much sense uh
The Rook will not be doing all that much
here and you're just going to REM
maneuver the bishop to A5 and B4 to put
more pressure on D6 so Shiro goes for
the for the humanlike move Rook to f8
and now Anan just goes Rook to G6 again
like we said uh capturing the Knight is
not a threat because Bishop captures and
the Queen guards the checkmating square
that is the H7 uh so Rook H5 attacking
the queen and queen to E6 now can shirov
trade Queens here uh not really if you
go for a queen trade here then there's
this monster pass Pawn on E6 and even if
you go after the pawn uh H4 now look at
this beautiful move and now after Rook
captures on H6 Rook H to G1 and how do
you defend the bishop here there's
really no good way to do it if you go
Rook E7 uh defending the bishop then
just Bish Bishop to d8 and that's it
once the The Rook moves you're going to
capture on F6 and after Bishop captures
of course this is Checkmate as I'm sure
you did not forget about our good friend
the light Square Bishop on B1 so after
Queen E6 Rook to G5 was played again uh
fighting uh against being checkmated uh
but now Rook captures on G5 H captures
on G5 and now not Rook to G1 the move
You're Expecting but rather Rook to D1
and shirov is uh really struggling to
find moves here what do you play here uh
the D6 Pawn is hanging so obviously you
have to do something about that he plays
Queen to D7 trading here again not best
because then also the D6 Pawn will be
hanging so he plays Queen to
D7 uh defending the pawn and saying okay
the capture the trade of Queens might
not be so bad for me if it happens on D7
uh but uh Anand goes for it because it
is very strong Queen captures Knight
captures and now the bishop is attacked
but the bishop just moves to C7 and this
this is something that you have to keep
in mind when your opponent offers you a
queen trade let's just go back a few
moves uh if the Queens come off the
board what are the weaknesses in Black's
Camp well G5 Pawn is weak D6 Pawn is
weak and B5 Pawn is weak and the the the
D6 and B5 weakness can be attacked
fairly easily so you know trading Queens
makes sense so Queen captures Knight
captures and Bishop C7 goes after the
pawn so of course Shir of defends it but
now Bishop to D3 going after the B5 Pawn
Knight to C5 there's no way to defend it
so you have to find some counterplay uh
just Bishop captures on B5 we have Pawn
to E4 shirov would of course enjoy
creating a pass Pawn himself now Bishop
to B6 preparing to capture Here and Now
start advancing the past D Pawn so
Bishop to f8 trying to keep control of
the D6 Square once the capture happens
uh but it doesn't really do all that
much for alexe uh we have Rook to E1 now
Anan could capture on A4 but he even
prevents uh E3 why give your opponent
any chances uh but shirov finds a way to
push forward he sacrificed IES a pawn to
get F3 a pass Pawn so F captures Pawn to
F3 and now Anon just goes Bishop
captures on A4 uh Pawn to C4 stopping
Pawn to B4 if you allow that then you're
going to have uh like four pass pawns to
worry about uh now bsh back to B5 Anand
will capture it but at least shirov want
some time here so Rook H6 going after
the H3 pawn and if shirov can eliminate
the H3 Pawn then G4 G3 and already there
are pawns on G3 and F3 so Anan says all
right C4 is nice but my H3 Pawn is much
nicer controlling the entire position F2
attacking The Rook Rook to F1 and now
Bishop to C5 if Anand captures on F2
then Bishop captures on E3 with check
will win the exchange later on you can
play Rook to D2 but still no reason to
do that Anand just starts advancing the
past E Pawn now uh Rook to F6 now comes
Bishop to B5 now it's time to eliminate
this Pawn Rook to F4 going after the E4
pawn and now Anan just trades Bishop
captures Rook captures and Bishop back
to B5 uh Rook to E3 again going for the
H3 Pawn but now just Pawn to D6
capturing uh here would be even though
it seems like you can capture it now
would be a pretty bad idea after Rook E1
checking the two Bishop captures The
Rook is defended black is now winning so
instead Anan just continues uh the game
he starts pushing his pass Pawn even
giving up the pawn but then he
eliminates the F2 pawn and then shirov
has no no more threats so but captures
Rook captures on F2 Rook captures on H3
shirov does have the pass G Pawn H but
just Bishop to D7 attacking The Rook
also preventing Pawn to G4 Rook to G3
and now King to C2 we have Pawn to G4
now Rook to D2 attacking the bishop
Bishop C7 and just Pawn to A4 we have
Rook to G1 hoping to get that pass Pawn
down the board but an just played Bishop
to C6 and he was in this position on
move 58 that Alexa Shiro resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here it's such a such a masterful way of
ending the game putting the bishop on C6
on a light Square to control G2 with the
bishop and the rook and since shirov has
a dark Square Bishop you know that um
even if you get like 10 moves in a row
that pawn can never reach the G2 Square
uh there's no way to control it of
course the king is too far away there
are no moves that you can make here and
anan's game plan is very simple just B4
C4 B5 C5 and then B6 and the pawn you
know uh any pawn just becomes a queen
and that's pretty much it uh with zero
counterplay from shirov here you can't
even improve the position slightly by
getting your king into the game because
then Rook D7 check picks up the bishop
on C7 so uh shirov played a great game
very tactical game very resourceful
pretty much in every uh position but
after missing that one one key move of
just keeping the pressure uh it was all
on and uh you know this was all all all
incredible all incredible and then with
Bishop to F5 he dropped the ball and
from Bishop to F5 onwards after move 21
Anan just took control over the entire
game but with E4 it would have been very
very tricky E4 of course is something
that you might expect from shirov but I
mean you can't you can't play you know a
brilliant brilliant move absolutely in
on every move in every position uh but
Anand obviously could and uh he took the
game by uh W winning and uh yeah he
started the tournament with a win so
very nicely done by Anan against the
master of the Mystic Arts Alexi shirov
we'll probably check up on some of
anan's other games from this tournament
uh if they are you know interesting and
uh I'm sure they are so we will cover
them uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it very nicely done by both
of them but Anand was the better player
here I would like to thank Welsh fan
Sasha Viller Mark Henley Brenan Michael
mes and Frank Banner for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day